if you're in the service business this
videos for you so just right now I want
to I'm in Boston right now by the way
this place is hot it's happening if
you're from Boston there's some special
about people in Boston there's some real
special about people in Boston
we just went to Fenway Park watch the
game my first time in Fenway Park had a
blast here for some reasons with some
other business people but anyways look
service very basic I was literally about
to go down to a restaurant down there
you don't see it it's called Island
Creek oyster bar I'll put the Yelp
account so you can see it it's four and
a half star 1900 reviews I was so
looking forward to going to that place
this is why service is so critical when
I hire front desk clerk I can't ever be
a front desk clerk I can't ever be a
hostess I can't ever be the first
first contact with a customer because
I'm not built to be a front desk clerk
I'm not built to be a hostess my
personality is probably not going to be
the best hostess I could be a behind the
scenes or I could be a waiter but maybe
not a hostess right and again that's a
service why because you got to pick the
most approachable likeable people that
have a pleasant smile and their
tolerance is just lowering we just want
to Island Creek oyster bar oh my gosh
I mean she's in front of me on the
phones for three minutes okay
not once looks at us nothing and three
minutes later she says how many in the
party I said three she grabs three menus
and starts walking not saying police
follow me I'll get you table I'll get to
the table she still hasn't spoken to me
and then we come over here we're at
Eastern Standard right there behind me
okay
we've never been here before it's got
nice reviews front desk hostess sweet
gentle kind patient please let me get
you a nicer table if you could wait five
more minutes
I will get you a nicer table to have
privacy I understand it's loud let me
see if I can get this place for you I
can sit you down right now by the bar
but it's not the best table I don't
recommend it it's up to you either way
you're gonna get great service but if
you go on the side I'll get you the best
table if you can wait five more minutes
and we said okay sure that's service so
I tell you this because if you're
watching this be extremely listen I have
a early part of my career I was not very
meticulous about this area I don't pay
attention to it until I realize how
important of a role the first contact
plays when somebody speaks to them and I
had somebody who was with me her name is
Alexa still today she's been with me
she's gone from you know initially being
an extremely part-time front desk person
to now I mean
you know she's doing extremely well for
herself with her job and I'm not talking
extremely well like making three four
five thousand dollars she's doing very
well for herself and she started as a
front desk you know why because she made
everybody feel good everybody feel good
I don't care if you're running a massive
business or if you're running a small
business if you're running whatever type
of a business you're running just make
sure whoever that is the first person
people touch is as pleasant approachable
nice patient kind as they get a CEO
sometimes tend to get a lot more credit
then we need to get because without the
person at the front there is no contact
with the CEO that always the restaurant
Island Creek whatever it is called
just lost the four hundred dollar bill
tonight tonight it's not a big deal
they're not gonna be hit by but there's
a video being talked about it just
because the front desk post this didn't
treat customers well they just want
service I'm not going there because you
know you know just going to a restaurant
I'm just going to for service I'm gonna
try the food I heard about it I'm at the
Fenway Park I'm leaving a game I'm here
with 200 other business people that do
20 30 40 50 million dollars of gross
revenues or more per year some even to 3
billion a year we're here strategizing
we want to go to a nice restaurant so
again I don't want to do a long grants
it's been four minutes and 32 seconds I
told myself be less than five minutes
think about who you hire that your
customers your market whoever it is that
reaches out to find out about your
company think about whoever touches it
first the experiment Achilles about who
you find that handles that important
I'm out of ammo blossom for here like
you know what